as they say three is the magic number
and i think the third episode of moon
knight is probably my favorite disney
plus mcu entry so far i absolutely love
the trip through egypt and it ends on a
cliffhanger that has a lot to unpack
from it throughout this video we're
gonna be breaking it all down as there's
a massive amount of easter eggs hidden
details nods to other movies and things
you missed yes you that's why you're
here don't lie now god damn it if you
love the video then please hit the
thumbs up button and make sure you
subscribe to follow us on this journey
that eclipses any other show without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into moonlight episode three
chump see ya chump now we begin with
layla picking up a passport from an old
friend desperate to catch it with mark
she's had to take the long way around
and fly to egypt whereas we saw last
week that there was somewhat of a jump
from london
[Music]
i did think that mark also flew out
there and there was certainly a gap in
time that we were in privy to due to him
being splashed out on the bed looking
like he'd had a long night of watching
morbius stephen was in the mirror and we
sort of saw from his perspective how he
went from one place to another in a
second flat like he got an apartment
abroad second flat apartment abroad your
mum's abroad god damn i'm nice but i'm
not a rapper however in this episode we
learn that there are passages that the
gods have access to that can allow you
to get around faster than we upload
breakdowns though conscious says just
the any ad tend to do this having this
ability would explain why layla is a bit
behind mark and having to get a passport
done quickly the person carrying them
out also clearly knows who mark is and
as we saw last episode he had a passport
and lock up potentially also being
something that was made by this woman
the guy has lots of secret identities
and steven would need a form of id to
get a job so potentially mark ended up
going to her to get one created for him
in this episode we get a very big hint
towards jake lockley being a part of the
show and in case you don't know this is
the third personality that we haven't
been introduced to yet
for what it's worth i had it under
control until very recently mark kind of
confirms that he's well aware of steven
and that he's been the one covering
things up whilst it seems like jake has
just been going balls to the wall with
it this is all theories at the moment
but we did get a shot in episode one of
some postcards at steven's work and he
was also leaving voicemails to his
mother in the comics mark's mother died
when he was very young and therefore i
think that mork set up a line and has
been sending steven post cards to make
it look like she's abroad not abroad
like your mum hey again world-class mum
jokes on this channel skies not like you
get on screen crush without crap shut
the [ __ ] up ryanairy now mark would also
have to be the person trying to buy
onefin goldfish so that steven wouldn't
think anything was amiss when he woke up
beyond this if mark and layla were still
technically together then i don't think
that he'd have organized a date with
another woman like he did in the first
episode layla says that his new
apartment is just 20 minutes from their
old place
and then i i found him with the scarab
living 20 minutes from our old place
so yeah if the guy was organizing dates
it's very very risky now he'd also
surely know that stephen was a vegan and
avoid a steakhouse at all costs so to me
jake organized the date and mark has
probably been trying to cover everything
up because of this i think jake might
have been a personality that's been
popping up in the show and it's just
mark who's been getting the blame for it
now there's two major moments in the
episode where we might actually
encounter him known for his thick accent
you can actually hear this coming
through listen to the pronunciation and
how it sounds slightly different to
mark's voice i'm looking for sinful
what sarcasm you doing here you should
be here watching what this joker just
puts on normal mock games in his
backyard for fun looking for centuries
sarcophagus
hello what
what are you doing here you should be
here
so what this joker just puts on normal
mock games in his backyard for fun super
subtle yet but the pronunciations are
slightly different and potentially we
might even get jake say hey i'm talking
here beyond this the character also has
what i believe is a chicago cap in the
first scene and throughout all the
comics jake wears one too he's also kind
of a douche to layla and seems way more
stern we did theorize last week that the
guy who looked in the cctv at the museum
could be him but yeah we might be
reaching anyway that's the end of fury
time every time every time
now we get a split second shot of
layla's name on the passport and her
surname is al fowley with her middle
name being abdallah this might be a
possible reference to abdullah othman
who is a stuntman for the show her job
also says antiquities dealer and this is
likely her real occupation because of
how she knows her character later on
interestingly she's not traveling under
the surname specter and this could be
due to the divorce or potentially to
avoid being flagged up as she's
traveling to egypt we learned she hasn't
been there for 10 years and that she was
trained by her father this makes her
extremely in line with marlene from the
comics his dig sites are mentioned and
we learn he also called her little
scarab i wonder what your father would
think of his little scarab now
you think his dig sites were any place
for a child
now in the source material marlene was
at the dig site that mark traveled out
to with ralph bushman after bushman
killed all the archaeologists there he
ended up leaving mark at that store and
this was when he was carried before the
shrine of konshu he became the avatar
moon knight and it's likely that we'll
see this all play out in the series now
marlene's father was murdered at the dig
by bushman and judging by the police
report that we got last week leila might
end up learning this information later
on harrah reveals to her that mark knows
more about her dad's death than he's let
on and this causes a lot of tension in
the car ride they have mark ended up
avenging marlins further and you'll
probably have to avenge yours after i
called your mom abroad twice in this
video which i take accountability for
and i actually apologize over that i'm
sorry now layla picks up a green
passport but you should have got a blue
one because that's the major thing we
got out of brexit was it worth it
moving on now we could do the title
sequence and we get another piece of
music as opposed to the usual marvel
fanfare episode one had engelbert
humphreys man without love and then two
went back to the fanfare but we have
another jam here this is entered by dj
kaboo which samples water by bat when i
speak
[Music]
now this is also a piece that timberland
took for aliya's i don't know what to
tell you the sample for big pimpin
popped up in episode 1 which he produced
and much like what we have here the
sample not being clear timberlanded him
in hot water i know i used that joke
before but it's a good one now cut to
the desert and we find harrow with his
followers and the golden scarab compass
there's a very raiders of the lost dark
feel to it and the creative team behind
the show cited this is one of their
inspirations for the series the poster
for this actually appeared in mark's
room in the jeff lemire run which this
show is also taking heavy inspiration
from scarabs are symbols that were laced
throughout ancient egyptian culture and
they typically tended to be associated
with wisdom regeneration and longevity
which is why they were placed on several
teams harrow is also joined by the two
policemen that he was with last week
including officer fitzgerald an irishman
that might be not demoli fitzgerald aka
shamrock in the comics and shout out to
eric versus new rockstars for pointing
out that fitzgerald and kennedy are
probably nods to john f kennedy dc
fitzgerald and d.c kennedy here it's
gerald and kennedy interesting names for
detectives because it's the middle name
in the surname of the u.s president john
fitzgerald kennedy because these are
probably fake names recognizable to an
american but less so to a brit actor ann
atkin jiren is credited as bobby and
david gainley as billy i didn't spot
that in my episode 2 breakdown so
congratulations eric i'm as stupid as
brit who fell for it too however let me
perhaps one up your reference with their
first names which are bobby and billy
these are actually the names of the two
orderlies in the jeff lemire run that'll
reveal to be working for omit so take
that your punk and i tell you what
ryanairy you take that one too you
haven't done anything wrong i just don't
like you shut the [ __ ] up ryanairy bad
news is that mark is close by two and we
get an awesome action sequence in which
he sprints across rooftops in order to
meet a contact very fast vibes here and
the moment has flashes of casino royale
as well as inception in the chase scenes
that were part of those movies the
contact is killed and in another nod to
raiders we get some fancy knife work
like the sword play in that film it
ain't enough and mark busts out some
hand-to-hand moves and slaps a kid
across the face like he just did a gi
chain joke the choreography here is
brilliant and isaac's really shows some
amazing techniques that we got hints
towards in his moonlight training videos
that were posted online last year he
comes close to killing one of them
however steven talks him out of it in
the reflection of the knife which is
such a creative way to have them go back
and forth i really love the use of
mirrors throughout the whole season and
steven seemingly takes over the body
during this time we get purple flashes
and this somewhat mirrors the colour of
the purple boat ride that we get later
on as well as conscious magic at the end
it's likely that in the series that
moonite's power is somewhat brought out
of the dark dimension and each magic in
the mcu has its own specific colour
purple is of course the dark one which
is why we see dormammu and agatha
harknessing it in in the shows now
orange is standard red is chaos green is
trickster magic and golden is cosmic
really nice attention to detail here and
mark wakes up in the back of a cab now
this could be a minor hinted egg luckily
who was a cab driver in the comics
probably reaching but if i don't say it
someone in the comments will and i'll be
sat here for a week thinking
i'm a [ __ ] and this is why my dad
doesn't talk to me suddenly all those
mum joke projections they make a lot of
sense now i do think that steven
probably took over at this point which
is why the driver says they're heading
to the airport where are you taking me
you are said the airport
he just wants to get out there as
quickly as possible but mark wants to
remain behind kind of funny how he
decides to attempt to talk to the guys
and they're just absolutely terrified of
him it leads to a chase scene that we
don't get to see in full as there's
another jump after he's hit over the
head i do really hope at some point that
we see the blanks filled in in the show
as there's so many scenes like the
cupcake fight that i'd love to see play
out in full the mark gets smacked over
the head and he collapses which is when
we do a jump cut he goes from holding a
guy up against the wall to then holding
a knife in him and it's such a brutal
scene that you really don't expect to
see in an mcu show now a big question
that you probably have is why didn't
mark wear the moonlight costume at any
point during this and it's clear at this
moment in time his powers are just
linked to the moon and also the night
moon knight see clues in the name and i
think we will only likely ever see the
suit come out when it gets dark and
daytime scenes will just have him like
this konshu is of course the moon god so
it makes sense his powers would be
linked tonight and it would also explain
how he's able to cause an eclipse as
well as the change in the night sky that
he does at the end of the episode again
as we mentioned earlier this is likely
jake who carried it all out and it's
clear he has no qualms about killing he
was pretty much a lowly guy who kept his
ears to the street and used to get
information from people by being a cab
driver his main informant was a man
named crawley who we know from the
credits is the loving statue that popped
up in episode 1 and 2. typically jake
isn't really a killer in the comics
however they've changed him up for the
show steven is a rich millionaire
playboy in the source material that's
often compared to bruce wayne so they
could have done something different with
jake to make mark and steven more than
just two-face a little batman pun there
now he tries to get info from the kid of
the group that he refused to hurt badly
before however rather than giving up
harrow's location he cuts his tie after
saying praise amit
[Music]
it really shows the devotion that
harrow's followers have and that they'd
rather die than betray their leader and
god now this scene also heavily riffs on
the james bond movie the spy who loved
me in that roger moore does an
eyebrow-raising interrogation where he
dangles jaws his partner over the edge
of a roof in egypt holding onto his tie
he asks some questions and this is then
smacked away like what we have here
where's peckish pyramids
may just be a coincidence but i think
the setting in form of interrogation is
very similar bun just says freckish
feckish and lets him die think we
avoided a yellow ad icon there without
one now mark blames steven for going on
a killing spree and the ladder does the
same back he also calls consu a pigeon
me neither listen if you've got a
problem with the body count i suggest
you start listening to that stupid
pigeon this is because the guy looks
like big bird's skeleton however this
design wasn't always in place originally
he was more like a ghostly pharaoh
however this design changed over the
years that he became a lot more like a
bird moonaites heard that we later see
on also has somewhat of a big shape to
it and as i've been saying baby all
connected
now mark requests an audience with the
gods and konchu says this line that sets
up the ending of the episode
anger them enough
and they'll imprison me in stone
that doesn't sound so bad to me conchi
also brings up the protection of the
healing armor which explains how mist
and i can get speared later on and still
pump out videos every day even though
he's just had two kids akon she calls
together all the avatars of the gods
after blacking out the sun and this is
very similar to the wrath of god in the
bible after pharaoh refused to let my
people go god sent 10 plagues to egypt
one of them being darkness like what we
get here now what's a pharaoh's favorite
chocolate ferro rocher hey another one
i've done there but it's great anyway
harrow is alerted by this and he's
called upon to come to the meeting of
the eniad we discover konchi was
banished by the gods the last time they
spoke and he's very much getting close
to his third strike the meeting is held
in the great pyramid of giza which is a
nod of the first episode when the girl
littered the model of it after saying
there was nothing there
looks like someone was stuck the great
pyramid of gaza over a rubbish dump it's
not like there's anything in there
so that was a lie and there's a gigantic
room adorned with statues of the gods
inside giza we get several geezers and
also the avatar of hathor
and who are you i'm jetseal avatar of
hattor
athol or heythor is the goddess of music
and love and she was also a character in
marvel comics the gods take over their
avatars and we hear the names of the
others like horus and osiris there's
some great back and forth between them
all and my boy oscar just gets to chew
the scenery as he lets conscious inhabit
his body now a big question that always
pops up whenever god characters are
introduced this light into the mcu is
where were you guys when thanos was
snapping his fingers like my wife when i
don't take the bins out well just like
the eternals the gods decided not to
interfere with humanity turns out humans
turned against the gods and basically
stopped worshipping them so they took a
step back all they do is observe however
khan she remained on earth and tried to
help out where he could now conju calls
for judgement against star the harrow
because as we know he plans to release
ahmet now we don't know exactly what
happened with the guard but it's clear
that something bad made them destroy the
creature they hid where she was buried
and left the knowledge with one person
in case they ever changed their minds it
is possible that this was hinted at in
the first episode when we had the poster
of the any ad
what i'm trying to point out i'm not
trying to slag off marketing but there's
been a major blunder because they've got
seven gods here and the onion has nine
we're told there's two gods missing and
this could potentially be omit and
konchu there are seven at the temple i
believe so yeah kinda seems in line with
what was said in the first entry now
there's also the mention of the other
void and in the jeff lemire run we
discovered this through the eyes of mark
it's basically a void outside of time
and space that can be manipulated and
changed into whatever the gods see fit
now initially it started off as an
insane asylum and mark was made to be a
prisoner of overseen by dr emmett who
was actually omit she attempted to trick
him into believing his entire life was a
fantasy and that he'd been in the
institution since he was a boy she also
had jackals masquerading as orderlies
which explains why harrow is able to
summon them so easily mark managed to
escape and we had lots of crazy twists
and turns with stephen believing that he
was in a tv show called moon knight
whilst jake thought he was in a 70s noir
taxi driver film it was also a moon
knight who thought he was a space pilot
on the moon called moon knight and it
had lots of very off-the-wall
storytelling styles we constantly jump
back and forth between the characters
and it's a real head when you read it
now in the end it was revealed that
konchu had infiltrated mark's life as a
child and that he wanted to fully take
over his body he'd created the entire
thing to try and break him and i'd love
it if the series went this way in the
end we have seen shots in the trailer
and credits that look like they're in a
psychiatric hospital and it would be
great to have an episode like that we
also see lots of little statues as
harrow enters and these seem to be very
similar to the one that konchi gets
placed in typically when someone was
mummified their organs would be put in
pots like this but i think they're way
too small to carry what was typically
put in them unless it's you mate yeah
with your little small organ you know
what i'm talking about anyway arthur
harrow is completely in denial and he
belittles konchu mark and also steven
the show is very much a comment on
mental health and how people who suffer
from issues are often overlooked and
just thought of as delusional it's easy
for people to gaslight and manipulate
others into thinking that those with
mental health issues shouldn't be
listened to and harrow carries out these
tactics to make it seem like more cannot
be trusted it also calls in a question
conscious judgment and harrow is allowed
to go about his business however hathor
realizes what's going on and due to her
relationship with konchu she gives mark
some advice one man a majority named
senfu he was tasked with recording the
location of the tomb in case the gods
ever changed their minds at this point
layla catches up to mark and the pair
travel out to meet anton mogot now if
you've been paying attention to what's
been going on behind the scenes then
you'll likely already know that this is
going to be midnight man sadly gaspard
earliel who plays him recently died in a
skiing accident and it sucks watching
these scenes now knowing that he never
got to see them guy hedges made it to
the mcu and it's really heartbreaking
hearing how he sadly passed away before
the show's release rest in peace big guy
and i hope this character comes back
down the line so that we can see him in
the costume when the car comic's
midnight man is a master thief that
stole several high value works of art
and this is thrown on the blows with
moon knight at several points this is
their first meeting in live action
though and it very much leaves him
riding off into some smoke to likely
return at some point i'll do a more
in-depth breakdown on the character if
he shows up in full costume but their
real names are the same so i think
that's what's gonna happen now on the
boat ride to him mark and layla finally
have a deep conversation she wears a
crescent moon necklace which is of
course laced throughout moonlight's
costume and there's also a celebration
on the boat that has a song that the two
played at their wedding awkward mark
reveals that he's known about steven for
a long time and that he had it under
control until very recently this could
have been the emerging of jake's
personality but mark doesn't seem to be
aware of this it could also be because
of the dig that birthed him into
moonlight and the reason he doesn't talk
about it is because layla's father died
out there layla and mark then spot what
appears to be harrah's men and they show
up later on the scene to cause some
chaos mogart's arena has two pyramids at
it and there's also a mention of
madrapure he's looking forward to seeing
you after madrid i'm sure you two will
have a lot to talk about
this of course was a major location in
falcon the winter soldier that massively
pulls from the comics as we know anton
is a black market dealer and he could
have ended up doing trades with sharon
carter aka the power broker she too was
involved in some dodgy dealings and i
love how there's these little nods to
the greater world and on his pretty
fuming layla's got a man and he takes a
bit of a dislike to mark he and steven
have some great back and forth and it
very much gives us the idea that they're
stronger together steven is an expert on
all this stuff whereas mark is out of
his death but the two work in the
reflections to create a star chart now
one of the big criticisms of the show
has been isaac's cockney accent which
makes him sound like dick van [ __ ]
now i know there's several british
people that watch these shows who don't
think it's good but that might actually
be on purpose now mark is really
american and steven is a persona that he
ended up creating along with his accent
therefore if it's bad it could be
because mark never had the ability to do
a proper one and i actually quite like
that idea kevin feige has saved it again
if you can thank me with a million
dollars you jump see you chump
now steven folds the sheets and shapes
of pyramids and later on he puts them
together as a star he disarms anton's
bodyguard in a move that i believe was
also shown directly in the behind the
scenes fight training harold then
arrives and offers him even more buried
treasure and a purple glowy stick can't
turn that down mate he also brings up
leila's dead father and kinda confirms
what we talked about before with her
potentially hating mark once she learns
the truth he also destroys the
sarcophagus so that potentially the
tumor vomit cannot be located now at
this point conscious arrives and he says
do it
summon the suit from here on out we get
an amazing action scene with moonlight
and layla taking down anton's forces
moonlight's cape is shown to be a
crescent moon and he also does the go
random bullsh go now he throws out some
gadgets and gizmos and these include
spikes as well as moon rangs which i'll
never forgive them for not calling them
moonerangs you should call it moonrang's
kevin i'm [ __ ] secure anyway he
almost kills someone with his fists and
stephen takes control at this point he
then tries to use diplomacy to calm the
situation down
that's it all right time out that's it
time out guys let's all calm down yeah
impale like boromir he gives mark back
control and there's a really slick bit
where moonai impales someone on one of
the spears layla breaks her necklace
apart to reveal that actually karambit
which was somewhat seen in the recent
batman movie with the bat symbol anton
goes to kill her in a joust move and
moon knight seemingly gets him though
he'll likely be back in the car ride
they discuss layla's father and in a
great bit of costume design mark wears a
white hoodie that is of course ripping
on his moonlight costume steven also had
something similar on in the first
episode when meeting harrow and i love
how it comes back here in the desert
they try to piece together the map but
unfortunately they discover they need to
know exactly what the sky looked like on
that date at this time conscious steps
forward and reveals that he remembers
what this guy looked like on that
specific night the caging omit was a big
thing for all the gods and though he
says he remembers every night it's clear
that this one is stuck with him in a
really cool and atmospheric scene konchu
and stephen turn back the night sky so
that it aligns with the map and it's
moments like this that i think really
elevate the entry above all the rest
lots of flashes of pre-crime and
minority report as they rewind things
and it all brings out the correct
constellations unfortunately as a
constellation for doing this consu is
imprisoned in stone by the other gods
and they trap him by that he does
instruct stephen
when the gods imprison me
tell mark to free me
so going forward i think they might
launch a rescue attempt to save him at
some point they now know where omi is
though and will likely be heading
straight there in the next century in
the end though konchi is trapped and the
gods say that he can probably hear
what's going on as we learned last week
harrow was the old avatar of the god and
he states he enjoyed dealing our pain in
his name i tell you a secret i enjoyed
dealing out pain in your behalf now in
the first entry we watched as he put
shards of glass into his channels and
this was very much carried out as a
religious penance showing his devotion
harrow hid this from everyone and every
step he takes every breath he makes
would be extremely painful because of
how much it would sting hey having that
you should call the police for how bad
that pun was now he states that he
learned from this pain though and that
he now knows the value of healing he
promises to do what konchu could not and
the episode ends with him saying
your torment forged me
i owe my victory to you
so as i'm sure you can tell i really
enjoyed this midpoint of the series and
everything feels like it's all coming
together setting the entry in egypt was
such a nice change up from london and
this was an entry that was laced with a
lot of cool visuals action scenes and
character choices conscious sacrifice at
the end was so impactful and though he
will not be back i thought it all played
out really well to give the series
stakes so overall great episode and i
hope that you enjoyed our breakdown of
it i'd of course love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you comment below
and let me know and i tell you what mate
you better be back next week now we are
in accommodation right now and giving
away three copies of spider-man noe home
on the 15th of april and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on twitter
heavy spoilers you want something else
to watch that's a moonlight related then
video on screen right now right here
right now you better click it otherwise
i'm blocking you
if not i promise i won't you know wait
it's it's been a long morning but uh
thanks for watching until the end i've
been paul you've been the best and you
know what enjoy the rest of your week i
hope you're bloody too i know i will
take care peace